we're very excited to be launching a new
program this January it's it's a program
called the program and innovation and
entrepreneurship this is a part-time
program is modeled on our very
successful summer program the Summer
Institute for Entrepreneurship it's
about a 60-person program and it'll
involve some students for graduate
students at Stanford University and not
in business and some students who come
from industry from organizations largely
in Silicon Valley and these students
will come together and what they have in
common is that they have ideas that
they're interested in commercializing so
this is a program designed for people
who on the one hand want to learn some
of the fundamentals about business and
on the other hand want to take those
fundamentals and apply them to
entrepreneurial ideas that either they
come into the program with that they
want to develop within the program or
which they're they're expecting to have
down the road so if you're interested in
learning how to turn an idea into a
business or if you're inside a
corporation and you want to learn how to
be more effective at moving your ideas
and projects forward this is a program
that may be of interest to you